this week's pet project and amy lee
joins us from the nspca and she brought
along someone
who needs a safe and good home you got a
dog there named
izzy well first off happy belated
birthday amy lee
you and tell us about tell us about
thank you so much pep this is izzy and
i've already
fallen in love with her i mean she's the
cutest little dog
um she's eight years old and she is
ready for a loving home of her own i
mean i'm already like
i want to take her home with me but i
can't otherwise i'd have like 500 dogs
in my house
um but she's such a sweetheart she looks
so calm so relaxed so how old is she she
she looks like a pup is she still a
young dog
she does she's so soft she's eight years
old but she's really sprightly like i
mean i was walking around the lobby and
i'm like this dog has so much
pep in her staff she's adorable she
loves actually she prefers the company
of females i think she just kind of
feels
we'll save no offense to the guys out
there but i think she warms up to
females
she does she is shy so it takes her a
little bit just to come out of her shell
but once she does she's really bubbly
super sweet she's best as an only dog is
she how is she on a leash so
walking her she's great on a leash how
she handle the walks
she's a dream she's like just such an
easy wonderful sweet dog that just wants
to
she crawled up on my lap and gave me a
ton of kisses and i mean she's just a
doll i mean we just want to find her a
great adult home
um just a mellow home that would give
her tons of love i mean sit on the couch
with her
take her for walks she's a sweetheart
she's a real real great dog no someone's
watching right now they got a couple of
other dogs and they're interested in
izzy can how
how can they meet can they come down and
hang out with izzy to see if she gets
along
with their current dogs how does that
process work for some dogs that are okay
with other dogs and we do stipulate that
on our website in their bios um
absolutely we want you to bring your dog
to a meet-and-greet with izzy's case in
particular she prefers to be the only
dog she's a little
funny about other dogs um so she would
be best as your one and only
an adult home and we put that all in her
bio which is on our website at
nevadaspca.org
it's a great thing so you can find that
in advance if they prefer other dogs if
they want to be solo
we truly appreciate amy lee and we'll
definitely find izzy at home because she
is
absolutely adorable thank you so much
and if you're interested in adopting a
pet go to nevadaspca.org or call them at
702-873-7722 las vegas now will be